as you can expect and neighbors were
shocked to find out what was discovered
in that garage madison kimbrough
continues our team coverage tonight
after speaking with those living in that
community
neighbors shaken up tonight describing
this neighborhood as quiet and kid
friendly one neighbor even sharing that
she may have known the kids involved
my mind is blown i really feel for that
mother and that child the child that had
to bring a note to school
it's really surprising and heartbreaking
at the same time as a mother neighbors
in this northeast valley neighborhood
reeling over the news that a child was
found dead in a garage freezer just a
couple doors down me and my kids walk
down that way to go down to the kind of
park grassy area
never thought anything never seen
anything it's very quiet in this
neighborhood so this is very surprising
residents saying they either didn't know
the family or would gesture an
occasional hello when driving by one
neighbor who lives about a block down
says after hearing the news she cried
realizing that she may have known the
kids involved they would come and ask
about our dogs and our motorcycles
and it was just now that we think about
it we just i wish there was something i
could have done i wish i would have
known because they'd always come and
just wait by the door or wait by our
garage like they're trying to hide
which is was a little weird test at
first we're like okay i don't know why
what's going on and they always came
from that direction so that's why we
were
thinking it might have been them
we've been told that a candlelight vigil
and walk will be held tomorrow around 6
30 in this housing development for the
deceased child reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now